the Joe Rogan experience these parts of
the world where people are willing to
harvest things like that like how'd they
figure that out who was the first guy
that's like you see that [ __ ] beehive
up there right I'm gonna get some of
that honey dude right angle off a cliff
yeah good luck my friend saying this the
other day to some buddies who was the
first guy to figure out caviar who's the
first got to suck off a sturgeon and be
like mmm this is delicious you know good
point just eat everything they can fish
yeah and if you catch a sturgeon man the
whole village is eating yeah I mean so
I'm 910 feet long dude they're so bit my
friends John and Jen they live in
Alberta and they went sturgeon fishing
and they they caught them and put them
on their Instagram page and you're
looking at like that is a prehistoric
dinosaur right creature that thing is
enormous
those big scales down the sides and down
actually the weird mouth and whiskers
they're bizarre yeah there's something
about the way you're looking at them you
like I don't feel like you should be
catching that right there's too old yeah
yeah it's like you just should probably
leave that thing alone
I think that that might be one of the
you know there's there's a lot of those
North American things that they think
are monsters like Nessie mm-hmm you know
I like the Loch Ness monster they also
have like ones in Lake Michigan what do
they call it Lake Champlain they have a
Lake Champlain one and they think that
it might be sturgeon Oh interesting boar
see because you know if especially
because people have a tendency to
exaggerate if you see a ten-foot
sturgeon we're going to think it's a 25
do you know that um this is kind of
interesting they actually had documented
bull sharks stuck in the Great Lakes yes
I'd heard about the pretty amazing that
is nuts sharks swimming a thousand miles
from you know blue easy Anna up rivers
and getting stuck in the Great Lakes
well they're one of the rare sharks that
can breathe fresh water right at address
yeah so she goes yeah in and out of in
and out of fresh water you know they go
through osmoregulation they can get the
salt out or in whatever they need and
then go into the rivers spend time in
the rivers go back into the ocean to
hunt the inspiration for the movie Jaws
was apparently bull sharks in New Jersey
in a series of attacks in fresh water on
a river system right but near an ocean
I believe writing at a river mouth yeah
yeah that was my understanding yes
people were going into the river and
these bull sharks were killing them
right like in a river yeah what no no
where it's safe
well they're really aggressive right
yeah they have the highest testosterone
of any species of shark and so they're
just they're just jacked up yeah they're
just ready all the time like they're a
bullish and you know their shoulders are
kind of arched over their pecs are
locked and they just they look ready at
any time to just snap yeah they found
them all the way up in like Illinois
yeah yeah it's crazy [ __ ] like think of
the temperature in Chicago right now you
know and their shark swims all the way
up there cold-blooded monster yeah how
do they get into the Great Lakes well
they used to go up the Mississippi River
but I think with all the locks that are
in there now in place they just I think
the idea was that they got stuck there
when they were building the locks and
then they died out over time when when
was the last known sighting of one I
think some two years ago no there you go
they find him in has been won and found
in Iowa Texas I was shocked kidding I
imagined yeah we lost Billy bit by sharp
what was he surfing retinol he was in
Iowa right right he was plowing corn and
got killed by sure there might be an
[ __ ] really yeah Ohio Ohio
what how do they get in Ohio all those
rivers are connected yeah ha damn that's
amazing right Oh nature finds a way you
know whenever I look at those videos of
bears catching salmon and jumping up the
river like what was the first salmon
thinking when it decided hey I'm gonna
go up these rocks right back to the
place where I was born right and and and
and spawn there put a target on my back
yeah oh just gigantic [ __ ] bear
waiting to catch me in the air right
like those images of bears catching them
with their mouths as the salmon are
flying through the air so I make it up
the it's just but it's so weird like
what a weird system it's like nature's
assuring robustness they're sure
assuring that these fragile fish
don't make it right in order to be able
to make that trip to the ocean and back
to get through the rivers and streams to
survive you have to be rugged right and
so they're showing it now so they're
going upstream swimming against the
current oh oh and by the way here's a
[ __ ] 1800 pound banner looking to eat
you it's crazy it's so cool but that
that is a viable system is this is the
system that's been in place forever
right so strange right and and and that
you know we can destroy that so quickly
we put one dam in and that that ruins
that whole ecosystem for that River and
the Bears and the salmon the spawning
and you know we can remedy that we put
salmon ladders in and yadda yadda but
it's it's interesting that everything
seems so tough as you just said and at
the same time it's so fragile because we
you know we do one thing like put in a
hydroelectric dam and it ruins the
entire ecosystem yeah we were in Seattle
and in Seattle there's a place where you
can go and it's like underneath this
bridge and there's these clear
plexiglass walls and you can actually
see the salmon no little way through and
up the river and they were explaining
how they had put dams in and didn't
really understand the consequences of
putting these dams back when they did
and then all these salmon would go to
the mouth of the river where they
thought they were gonna go upriver and
it would be blocked right
and they has died and right and breed
and so the population drastically
diminished these salmon died and like in
the harbor yep like really wild stuff
yeah it's crazy and that supports you
know like that food source that protein
supports not just like the bears and the
birds but like the whole river is
ecology right like the river the lg's
that live in the river the little bugs
that live in the algae depend on those
salmon dying up that river and
fertilizing the river yeah so it's like
the whole thing is so interconnected and
then you know one little thing and poof
did you yeah that is really crazy
[Applause]